was jetzt noch zwischen uns und der
nächsten gruppe steht ist nur noch die
alte tante spd gott stehe uns allen bei
die partei ist ja völlig verunsichert
angesichts der niederschmetternden
umfragen wenn sie dazu eine live analyse
in der neuen rubrik ganz unten von micro
sim slot
ja ich möchte heute mal privat werden
und über meine persönlichen krisen
sprechen ich bin ja immer in der krise
aber vor einigen jahren war ich an einem
besonderen tiefpunkt ich habe mich
gefragt was will ich mit meinem leben
noch anfangen was kann ich wirklich gut
und da ist mir aufgefallen wirklich gut
kann ich eigentlich nur zweifeln
resignieren andere menschen demotivieren
und dann habe ich mich natürlich gefragt
was kann ich mit diesen fähigkeiten mal
beruflich machen und dann ist mir
eingefallen spd-vorsitzender ich erzähle
diesem geld seit zwei jahren ist echt
erstaunlich was für eine konjunktur
diese plante so mitgemacht hat ich
glaube mittlerweile ich bin genauso wie
die spd
überfordert voller selbsthass und vor
allem nie für eine überraschung gut
die spd und ich wie erreichen nie unsere
ziele nur umgekehrt
ich sage immer dass ich scheitern will
und habe damit erfolg
die spd würde gerne erfolgreich sein und
scheiterte damit
es gibt unterschiedliche wege in eine
depression meiner hatte glaube ich mit
falschen lebensentscheidungen zu tun ich
habe zum beispiel ein bwl studium
angefangen
der fehler dabei war ich habe nicht
gefragt was ist das richtige für mich
als mensch wie kann ich ein schönes
leben führen sondern was kann ich für
die wirtschaft tun weil es jetzt auch
nicht was das mit der spd zu gehen hat
jedenfalls habe ich gemerkt mir geht es
schlecht damit ich bekam herzens angst
oder auf englisch hartz 4
eine fehlentscheidung war das
bwl-studium die fehlentscheidung der spd
war die agenda 2010
ich bekam eine depression die spd bekam
olaf scholz
gott sei dank hab ich nich to love
scholz bekommen und liebe spd völlig
egal wie das mit dem mitgliederentscheid
am sonntag ausgeht lasst mich euch noch
folgende motivierende worte zu rufen
[Applaus]